hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my legends of tomorrow episode 11
video just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen it yet it was called the
Magnificent 8 obviously a big reference
to the Magnificent Seven so here we go
this will probably go down as a lot of
people's favorite episode it's
definitely my favourite episode so far 1
because I really liked westerns 2
because if they're gonna riff on
something I really like it when they're
really upfront about it like they put it
right in the title magnificent 7
magnificent 8 now I'm gonna have to
explain a lot of Easter eggs there were
a lot of Western things going on in this
because it was a Western episode but it
goes way deeper than that because we
have Jonah Hex stuff from the comics so
you have a lot of DC comics Quentin
Tarantino iing going on in this episode
where they're paying homage to a lot of
really awesome things while doing a
really big comic book character and
Jonah Hex really was the highlight of
the episode this was meant to introduce
him to the TV universe and I love the
way they set his backstory up so let's
just go ahead and do top 5 WTF then I'll
explain all the comic book Easter eggs
you know talk about some of the really
awesome secondary Easter eggs for
western movies and the stuff they were
riffing on number 5
DC's Magnificent Seven so if you've
never watched the Magnificent 7 movie
it's a total classic it was made in 1960
but it was also a remake of Akira
Kurosawa's Seven Samurai from 1954 so if
you think it's really funny that
Hollywood reboots movies and other
genres in a really short span of time
they've been doing it for forever even
all the way back past the 60s in the 50s
so if you really want to go for bonus
points here just watch Seven Samurai
it's one of the greatest films of all
time but because this is TV in the doing
comedy they're really on the nose about
how the riffing on that the basic plot
of Magnificent Seven and Seven Samurai
is that a group of gunfighters a group
of samurai have to train a whole village
of regular people to defend themselves
from a group of bandits so that's why at
the end of the episode you see them
collectively fight off that enemy gang
even with their limited budget I felt
like they did a good job of hitting all
the Western tropes there's always a lot
of familiar tropes from spaghetti
westerns from American westerns like
there's the common theme of the person
who was run out of town previously or
someone who bailed and has come back
that's what you have with Jonah Hex and
rip hunter rip hunter was kind of run
out of town I can't believe you came
back after what you did
wanted posters or another big trope of
westerns Jonah Hex is wanted poster is
inside rips office if you really want to
go
cuts here a couple Western archetypes
that you can kind of see these
characters on screen
the gunslinger the retired gunfighter
the young gun the bandido
the highwayman the wrestler the retired
outlaw the Bounty Hunter
I've already seen tumblr launches ship
for rip hunter and Jonah Hex which I
totally think it's funny I think the
reason for that you know number four WTF
watch agonda you know introducing Jonah
Hex Jonah Hex and rip hunter used to be
a team rip hunter had that mental drift
that happened to the other characters
the previous week where they just kind
of forget about their normal lives and
they get sucked into like whatever time
and place they're in so rip hunter Jonah
Hex were working in this town it got
taken over by bandits and rip had to
leave while the bandits destroyed the
town that's why Jonah Hex was so pissed
at him when he saw him again you mean
you knew that was gonna happen and you
let it happen anyway so the only real
problem I had with that moment is is
that Jonah Hex isn't surprised at all by
the idea that rip hunters a time
traveler but knowing that he's a time
traveler he should have been able to
connect the dots that rip hunter would
have known what would end up happening
to that town but whatever it's just a
great funny moment when Jonah Hex walks
on the ship and is just like yep no big
deal like he's not surprised at all we
also learned that rip hunters coat used
to belong to Jonah Hex my coat suits you
well and rip hunter actually gives him
one of his advanced revolvers at the end
so lasting thought Sarge that Jonah Hex
is going to continue to exist in the DC
TV universe they'll just try and use him
at least once a year
probably specific to legends of tomorrow
if you've never heard of Jonah Hex
here's a quick backstory so he appeared
for the first time in all-star western
volume 2 number 10 in 1972 so he's
pretty old not as old as some DC
characters and it was basically a Dances
with Wolves type of story
his father sells him into slavery with
the Apache Indians and as he grows up he
eventually earns their respect and
integrates with their culture eventually
he falls in love with an Indian woman
things go crazy he almost ends up
getting killed but a US cavalry patrol
nearby saves him and ends up massacring
all the Indians so he reintegrates in
American culture and becomes a bounty
hunter he doesn't have any special
abilities he's just a total badass so
what you see is what you get if you want
to read some really awesome stories for
him you could read all-star western guns
and Gotham Joe
Hix face full of violence as in you know
fistful of dollars nice Clint Eastwood
reference Jonah Hex origins Jonah Hex
writers of the worm and such in Jonah
Hex - gun mojo but if you're not a big
fan of the western genre then don't
worry about it because they are Western
stories he's a Western character so even
if he's time-traveling is still a
Western story it's like sci fi western
number three WTF Ray Palmer
nuts up as John Wayne the names Wayne
this was one of my favorite Adam scenes
his character is meant to be the funny
guy on the team but I feel like he's
Fozzie Bear like he makes jokes but he
doesn't realize that he's telling bad
jokes so it's just really nice to see
him get this moment but number two WTF
even cooler than that we learn about
Martin Stein's backstory his father was
a scoundrel just like Captain colds dad
only his dad was a gambler these types
of moments are my favorite because this
is where you really learn about
characters and they can go a little off
but like this isn't from the comic books
this is an original creation of the show
Martin Stein in the comics is a little
less clearly defined he has some crazy
stories the character moments are what
make them real for you like he feels
like a real person now his dad was crap
so he learned how to gamble at a young
age but at a certain point when he was
growing up he did the Captain Cold thing
where he's like I'm not gonna be like
you dad I'm gonna try and make something
myself Captain colds life took a
different direction but you get the idea
they are cut from the same cloth they
come from very similar types of families
one of my number one WTF they are
targeted by the pilgrim only she's going
after their young self to erase them
from the timeline doing the smart thing
just go to the source kill the MIS
children that never lived to cause all
this trouble for the time masters the
real question is is who is the pilgrim
is she an original creation of the show
or she a TV version of a comic book
character now there is no character that
fits her description that is called the
pilgrim so that might just be a codename
when we find out if she has a real name
beyond the pilgrim then we could figure
out who she really is but they say that
she's basically like the Omega protocol
she's like the true bobafet of the time
masters the person who always gets their
man
remember Boba Fett collected on Han
Solo's bounty so even though he wound up
in the Sarlacc he still got his man but
let me know what you guys thought of
this episode what was your favorite
moment just meeting Jonah Hex
I know everybody wants him to come back
really soon I don't know if he's gonna
come back before the end of the season
you know at least come back for season
two and I totally love that Warner
Brothers in DC let the TV shows use this
character usually it happens the other
way around the movies will steal TV
characters like with the Suicide Squad
but if you guys spotted any other comic
book Easter eggs just let me know in the
comments this is one of those few
episodes without Vandal Savage they did
have some Hawkgirl stuff like she runs
into a previous version of herself I am
really not digging this Ray Palmer
romance story that older version of
herself was super cynical so obviously
things aren't quite so bad she doesn't
have to surrender to the idea that she's
a slave to the cycle of death and
rebirth but there is a new episode next
week the flash is back next week so be
sure to subscribe to get those videos I
will be doing a flash bonus video in the
next day or two and we have some Batman
stuff to talk about we have to talk
about Ben Affleck's new Batman movie so
those videos will all be coming really
soon while you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here to
learn about Deadpool 2 in what Tim
Miller the director was saying about
Spider Man crossover in the future and
you can click here to all about the
Spider Man homecoming movies that Sony
just announced thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight